thank you all for coming tonight and
welcome to Olsen's books and records in
Bethesda a few store items first for
those of you who are not signed up for
our email mailing list you may do so at
the information desk at the front of the
store it just basically lets you know
about events such as this one this
evening and speaking of which on Monday
afternoon at our Metro Center store
Senator John McCain will be signing the
paperback edition of his book faith of
my father's it's at the Metro Center
store 1200 F Street from 12:00 to 2:00
in the afternoon and on September 14th
which is a Thursday at the National
Press Club which is 14th and F streets
northwest we are presenting Doris
Lessing she will be reading and signing
copies of her new book then in the world
it is a sequel to the fifth child this
is a very rare and special appearance by
Miss Lessing she does not often come to
this country so those of you who are
interested I would urge you all to
attend it is a ticketed event tickets
are only five dollars and can be
purchased at any Olson's location or at
the door the night of the event Gucci
has had a very rich history from its
beginning as a leather shop in the early
1900s to its current incarnation under
young hip fashion designer Tom Ford not
the least of which was the tragic death
of Mauricio Gucci the grandson of the
company's founder Sarah gave orden
offers insights into the Gucci family
and the business empire she is currently
the editor and editor in chief of Luna
magazine please join me in welcoming
Sarah gave Borden thank
thank you and thank you all for coming
it's really exciting for me to be here
and to see so many friends and familiar
faces and also all of you who I don't
know but I hope to be able to share with
you a little bit tonight how this book
came into being and one of the first
things I'd like to say I'm glad that
Elizabeth mentioned Tom Ford he recently
gave an hour-long interview to Charlie
Rose and was a nice conversation and
Charlie's asking him how he goes about
designing all of these hot new fashion
styles and Tom was talking about how he
just keeps his antennas out all the time
he sends his design assistants out and
always looking for new trends new ways
of doing things new ways of wearing
things and that his job is then to take
all that information and turn it into a
thing and I had to say that really
resonated when this thing came out after
two years really of computer files and
manuscript pages and copy edited pages
and when I first got it and I realized
oh my god it's a thing and so I'm really
happy to share this thing with you and I
hope you'll enjoy reading it and
learning more about the Gucci story this
is a story that spans three generations
of Gucci's it started with a small
mom-and-pop handbag shop in Florence in
1921 founded by Gucci Gucci who was a
man who had a vision and his vision was
to make quality products for a European
traveling elite and they needed bags and
fine luggage to put all their wonderful
things into and so this was his dream
and over the generations he brought his
sons into the business and then they in
turn their sons and developed it from a
little really a little mom-and-pop shop
into what is today a multinational
luxury goods corporation
offices around the world stores and now
it's on the brink of really a new
chapter which will probably be the next
saga which is to do with new companies
that the company's acquiring the same
turnaround that they did with Gucci
named they've bought one of fashion's
greatest prizes it's been called by the
fashion press Yves son of all four a
French jewelry luxury Julie [ __ ] on
an Italian fine shoemaker Sergio Rossi
and so now the challenge is really to
pull all of these different labels into
one successful group just wanted to
pause a little bit and tell you how I
got into this story and it really
started when I moved to Milan in 1988
and started covering first just the
general business environment in Italy
and then in 92 the fashion industry and
this was a time when many of these
family founded or really sort of
single-person companies that were built
up around designers Giorgio Armani
Gianni Versace John Franco Fred a were
starting to grow from kind of
medium-sized businesses into big
business and at that time Gucci was
suffering from over distribution over
expansion its products were available
everywhere they brought out cheap canvas
bags plastic coated bags you could you
know buyers they used to call it the
drugstore image
it was extremely profitable but it had
lost the luster the luxury it wasn't
anything special to buy a Gucci bag
because anybody could have one and I
first met Mauricio Gucci who was the
last of the Gucci's to run the family
company in 1991 when he was really
announcing his whole plan again another
vision to take the company and turn it
back into a fine luxury goods firm and
his model was
the family firm at a mess so quality
products genteel
discrete elegance but very very special
things and he was a charming man
enthusiastic
one of the investment bankers who first
met him described him as a movie star
you know the glasses the camel coat the
name on the door of the company he
really had an ability to bring people
along and and just fill them with
enthusiasm for his for his plan
fortunately the results were not aligned
with the expectations and the spending
went out of control they spent millions
of dollars on new offices a headquarters
in Milan refurbishing the stores and
pretty soon after this sort of golden
launched I started to hear rumors about
everything that was going wrong with
this plan and people were leaving sales
were slumping you couldn't get the
products and it was really a fiasco in
the makings and that's when I started
covering the story of the battle between
Maurizio and his financial partners who
of course were very concerned about what
was happening to the bottom line and
that's really what pulled me in and over
the years I covered it for Women's Wear
Daily all the developments mojito sold
out in the end he was forced to sell to
invest core his financial partners and
at that point the story of the family
and the story of the company take two
different paths and the company goes on
to really one of the most unprecedented
successes it's quoted on the stock
market there's a fashion turnaround Tom
Ford and domain achill they slowly come
in and become really one of the most
unified creative and business teams in
the industry and together they really
turn Gucci around I guess that the thing
that makes the story though compelling
is that it's it's not just a business
story and it's really as you go
through it it's a story of strong
personalities from gaucho to his sons to
Mauricio and to the new team that came
in it's a story of high stakes because
this name has always been associated
with clamor with luxury and with
earnings potential and it's a story of
finance so we've got a modern takeover
battle and it's really as all the
elements of a real life novel and that's
for me what made it compelling and I
realized that it's not just that there
was more to say than you could say in a
daily news story but it really there was
enough here to to really tell it in a
book I'm leaving out probably them the
most sort of startling and unexpected
and unusual story in the whole book
which is the story of the murder of moti
Taguchi in 1995 and this was two years
after he'd sold out of the business he
was at the brink of a new life and for
the first time he was not dealing with
family battles I mean he'd he'd had
lawsuits board room coos every sort of
and every twist and turn imaginable at
one point he had to escape to
Switzerland to avoid being arrested in
his offices in Milan because he was
accused of exporting capital at a time
when capital laws were very strict in
Italy there were stories of flying
handbags at family product meetings in
fact one one story that really became
legend in the company was when the door
keeper came to open the gates of the
Gucci factory in Florence one morning
and this would have been probably in the
70s 80s probably in the 80s and he
gassed because the lawn around the
building was strewn with fine handbags
and he thought oh my god there's been a
break-in and he rushed to call the
police well what he didn't know was that
there had been a heated family product
meeting the night before and the
and bags had flown and some of them had
flown out through the open window and so
that's why they landed on the lawn so
these are people with they were not
sitting around waiting for life to
happen to them they were out there
trying to get as big a piece of the pie
as they could and at one point there
were dozens of court cases pending on
both sides of the Atlantic and one point
New York Supreme Court judge was closing
yet another one of these cases and she'd
already seen one too many and she
pounded her gavel on the bench and said
I know every piece in the Gucci line and
I know that two-thirds the price of
every wallet goes to pay lawyers fees so
these are people who were litigious to
say the least and they ended up trying
to resolve their conflicts over the
company more through through the courts
than in person and there are also
stories for example of an adult for who
was the son of the founder and he would
get furious at his brother Aldo who was
a the other son actually there there
were three but the third one died in the
early 70s so in the 80s that was the -
Rodolfo and Aldo who really divided the
company between them and he would call
his driver and get in the car and drive
the three hours from Milan to Florence
to confront the brother Aldo over
something that he wasn't happy about and
he would leave me Lonnie I've got to
talk to Aldo we got to deal with this -
moon anyway the anger would dissipate
during the ride and inevitably he would
arrive in Florence and when he saw Aldo
would be Joe Gatti Seymour let's go to
lunch
and they would never really confront the
differences so it was sort of smiles and
hugs it to each others face but the
knives would be pulled out as soon as
one of the other turned their backs so
um this was all to sort of get back to
Mauricio who's free for the first
I'm from these family feud's and he has
lost control of the company but he has
120 million dollars in the bank
he's founded his own company he studying
investments he has a beautiful luxury
apartment on in downtown Milan
he's trying to get custody of his
daughters because he and his wife have
been divorced and he's concerned that as
long as they're under his/her influence
he's never going to have a good
relationship with the girls who are
teenagers at that point and so he he was
really at the beginning of a new life
and it wasn't about you know Mauricio
Gucci in the family fighting it was
about what he was going to be able to do
on his own and the morning of March 27th
1995 he walked out of his apartment
across the street and 100 paces down to
where his offices were and as he stepped
in over the threshold and greeted the
doorman another man came in behind him
and fired four shots at him and the last
one hit him in the temple and that was
the shot that killed him and so in
addition to the story of family conflict
we now have a tragedy and a shocking
tragedy like I still remember I was in
my apartment on the other side of town
getting ready to go to work and a friend
of mine called she was working for
Reuters in Rome and she said Sarah
you're not gonna believe this but Mount
Isa good she's been shot and it just
seemed unreal to me I couldn't I
couldn't fathom this and that somebody
could be gunned down in cold blood on a
elegant Street in the middle of this
northern Italian industrial city and you
know there there are other cities in
Italy where people get gunned down but
they're usually Palermo Naples that's
usually sort of infighting between mafia
clans and it's really something that it
was was shocking not only to the people
in Milan but really to to everybody had
known about eats your had worked for him
or been a friend of his and so I rushed
down there and of course by that point
the police had put up the you know the
roped off the area and then ambulance
was there the body at that point had
been taken away but you know initially
there was a lot of speculation that it
had been the mafia and that maybe it was
a business deal gone bad or sort of a
shaky
you know shady deal or something in the
hotshot investigating magistrate who was
experiencing economic crime was put on
the case and for two years there was no
solution and for two years
patrice Iguchi Maurizio's ex-wife
thought that she had gotten away with
murder and this is a woman who had
actually come from modest beginnings but
her mother had married well she lived in
a beautiful home in Milan her father her
stepfather was a rich industrialist
she'd gone to translator's school and
her goal in life had been to marry not
just the rich husband but a rich husband
with a good name and in fact I talked to
some people who'd known her as a young
girl and at one point she was dating a
successful industrialist but she dumped
him because he didn't have a name and so
monito Gucci was the name and he was one
of the city's most promising young
bachelors you know great future family
business was extremely successful in
those days and he fell head over heels
in love with Patricia and petite she was
a petite woman um sort of with a short
complex he always teased her hair up as
high as she could to give herself some
height and walked around on stiletto
heels and you know mascara and the lips
and you know she was done and their
friends told me that they couldn't ever
understand what it was that my elites
you saw in her and they would sort of
joke among themselves and say you know
what can he see in her when she's sort
of step
down off the heels and takes off the
mascara but he didn't want to have any
of it he he wanted Patricia and he even
married her against the objections of
his father who felt that she was a gold
digger and would do no well and just was
after money and fame and Rodolfo was so
adamant about this that he even went to
the Cardinal of Milan to try and block
the wedding and he went in and he told
the Cardinal that you know he had to
stop this marriage that Batista was not
the right woman for Mauricio and Wyatt
and the Cardinal said that he was sorry
that if they loved each other there was
nothing that he could do and he would
not stand in the way of this wedding and
on the day that they were married the
daughter called his driver and went to
Florence because the whole city of Milan
was celebrating this wedding and not one
member of maurices family actually came
to the wedding so it was was really his
rebellion and he wanted Patrizia but for
a while he he had lost his family and
his father rejected him and he moved out
and went to live with Patricia's family
they provided a home for the young
couple and so there was a big rift in
the beginning this was later reconciled
and adult full and petite she eventually
sort of accepted each other although it
was never a really informed relationship
and they had thirteen happy years of
marriage they had the two daughters and
really what started to to tear the
relationship apart and reflection I
think was power and Mauricio had
inherited by that point his 50% stake in
the company from his father and Patrizia
was an ambitious intelligent dynamic
woman and she was pushing him to be you
know mr. big in the fashion industry and
this time a lot of the the other Milan
designers are starting to grow their
businesses there
opening you know big headquarters in
ateliers in Milan and practically she
was pushing and pushing and pushing and
pushing and some people said she really
beat him up and she started telling him
you know everything that he was doing
wrong and he became a sort of classic
henpecked husband and one day in 1985 he
packed a you know briefcase or overnight
bag to go down to floor it's on a
business trip and he never came back
and he sent a friend of his a doctoral
confidant the next day to Patricia
to tell her that Moniz he was not coming
back and according to the story a lot of
this is legend but actually found the
doctor he admitted it the doctor had a
bottle of Valium and his overand in his
little black bag because they were so
afraid of what petites his reaction was
going to be well she sent the doctor and
the value in packing and you know told
Marita if he had to leave her he should
have the courage to tell her to her face
and I think it was a while before he
actually did she sent another friend
Susie this is described in the book the
same elites is not coming back and she
was just furious and here all that she
had achieved was starting to slip
through her fingers and even after they
were estranged and then as the divorce
was coming through they were just
constantly constantly fighting with each
other arguing the girls the houses at
one point monito locks her out of the
chalet in San Moritz and she arrives
with the two girls and the locks have
been changed and so she calls the police
and says you know we're estranged but
we're not divorced you know is this fair
and they said no and so she made the
police open the locks and then change
the locks so that he couldn't get in so
so even even apart there was a very sort
of strong connection there in fact I
even interviewed an astrologer who had
done both of their charts and she said
because of their their sides these are
two people who would never again feel
that they had found the right partner
that they were even in conflict they
were they
still very very attached just a couple
more things that give us an idea of
patrizia's personality and dynamic and
she became famous for a line that she
made on television when the interview
asked her a question about values and
money and she said well she said I would
rather be crying in a Rolls Royce than
happy on a bicycle and that really
really said said a lot about her I guess
at this point and I've sort of given you
a bit of the flavor of this book and I
would be really happy if you have
questions just to open up to questions
and then we can move back and forth they
cooperate with you at all and and the
new partnership yeah oh well the Gucci
family is actually the person that I
spoke to the most in the families that
Alberto Gucci who was one of oldest sons
and he's still living in Florence and
has his own a leather goods firm luxury
leather firm called house of Florence
and he is very very very bitter I mean
it was almost a palpable I mean you
could see the shadows go across his face
and I would ask him you know how did it
feel when you sold your company and he
said it was like losing my mother and I
don't think this is something that you
ever get over and now you know there's a
family with a last name Gucci and
they're on the sidelines and it's too
late I'm sure they have regrets but all
the fighting really you know they were
more individually more focused on on
what each one was going to get out of
this company to the judgement of the
whole I haven't had feedback yet yeah I
sent off a couple of copies and if so
maybe I've got mail back at me lon I
would have feedback yet but um and in
terms of the company land I'm glad you
asked this because before
started on this project I had developed
relationships over the years through my
reporting with some of the key players
with Tom Ford with dawn Mello with
Dominical de Soleil and I as I started
think about the book I asked them if
they would cooperate because I really
felt that the quality of the book was
going to depend on the quality of the
information and of the experiences and
so I really had wonderful cooperation
all up and down the line from from the
company and also from invest Corp which
up to now has always sort of been a
faceless sort of anonymous institution
with respect to some of the the battles
that even happened and so I was able to
go and find the people who were working
on the deal who were buying out the
pieces of the company over the years and
find out sort of how they were seeing
things and what what was going on so I
forget what else is going to say do you
know anything about the first choice and
how did they go about the selection
process that's that's actually a great
story and it's in the book when invest
Corps had secured a complete control
over the company the chairman wanted a
famous designer to to design the
collection in fact he was he would often
drop the name of John Franco fella who
has been designing in Milan for many
years and the sort of advisors and
financial people had to say you know we
can't afford a big name right now I mean
the company had been on the brink of
bankruptcy people had left it was it was
a very difficult situation inves core
had been investing in this company for
eight years and had yet to see a return
so it had its own investors which were
pretty unhappy about this and meanwhile
Tom Ford had been there for several
years he'd been brought in by dawn Mello
who'd been brought in and turned by
Mauricio Gucci
and as all the designers left at one
point he was single-handedly designing
all 11 product categories for Gucci I
mean the guy was not sleeping he was
living on coca-cola and just producing
producing producing and it was actually
really key to what he's been able to do
at Gucci because that gave him a chance
to really know and understand intimately
every product in every product line and
you know how the shoe vamp has to be
designed in order to create a certain
effect or a certain look to you know how
the luggage or the gift items and so it
was a bit of a gamble and dawn Mello had
recommended him when she left she said I
think he can do it he's talented he's
young he's motivated and an interesting
thing and his story is how all of these
twists and turns kind of were either
fueled or coincided with people's dreams
and goals and tom was a young man who
was very focused about what he wanted to
do and he was telling his friends even
before he started working coach he said
I want to be a designer like Calvin
Klein so to create an image of a whole
world a whole lifestyle but with the
turnover of Ralph Lauren so when he got
to Gucci and you know here he was
working and stayed up all night
designing products one of the
collections in 94 when things were still
just at the beginning of the recovery
they had to hang the whole collection
themselves because there's nobody else
to do it I mean the guy was getting up
at 5 o'clock in the morning to prepare
the the show for them for that day but
he realized at that point he said that
he had at that point the opportunity to
really have exert control over a
significant luxury name and to do what
he wanted to do I mean he had the
freedom to do it and so he hung in there
even when other people saying it get out
he he says at one point he went to see
an astrologer in New York was kind of a
fashion astrologer and
said to him oh you've got to get out of
Gucci you know there's nothing there for
you you got to get out of there and he
didn't he hung in there and look where
he is today yes
how important is north america kedusha
are they stronger in Europe are just a
stronger which markets are most
important for well over the years
actually the North American market was
fundamental to Gucci success because it
was the American market that first
really recognized Gucci as a status
symbol and started buying Gucci in a big
way and that really started with the
Gucci loafer in the late 50s early 60s
and this was this was the product that
really turned Gucci from a carriage
trade product to a really broader appeal
in a broader market and at one point
Aldo Gucci even hires a public relations
woman in Rome because he says it's
impossible you know go she was famous
the United States it's more famous here
than in Italy and so he wanted to get
the buzz going in Italy too that said in
the next market that became very
important for Gucci was the Japanese
market and Gucci was one of the first
companies to actually open in Japan in
1970 early 70 71 72 because they
realized that Japanese buyers were
coming over to the Rome store to the
other stores and buying up you know 60
handbags and then going back and selling
them at however you know many times the
price in Japan so that prompted them to
then strike a local joint venture
agreement in Japan and open stores there
I don't remember the actual current sort
of division but the goal of most luxury
goods companies today is to evenly split
their business between Europe Asia and
the American markets and this was really
important especially if they're sort of
local cry
for example in 97-98 when we had the
Asian economic crisis Gucci's business
there was was a bit higher it was over
45% if I remember correctly and so you
know that proved a major a major problem
and they worked really hard after that
to try to redistribute and focus more
also on a local clientele to really
protect the company from these sort of
blips and crises okay but uh we got to
get back to that part of the story for
today's show
Patrizia was living in Maurizio's
luxurious apartment in costa Venezia
where she'd moved in after his death
with the two girls and this was despite
the fact that she actually had a
penthouse apartment a few blocks away
that Modi too had given her as part of
their divorce settlement so this is what
got me to start thinking you know she
could have perfectly well stayed in that
apartment and closed down Modi to his
apartment because it was a rented
apartment and so it was costing a
fortune the rent was four hundred
million lira which at this point you
know could have been no three hundred
thousand dollars so it really was you
know running down the family wealth but
I came to believe that she really wanted
to reclaim the status of la signora
Gucci and this was something that she
could only do with him out of the
picture because their divorce had gone
through in 1994 but Modi su was moving
to try and regain custody of the girls
he was living with a new girlfriend
there was talk that he might marry and
he was spending money like it was water
he had restructured this apartment he
filled it with antiques I mean he'd
redone the pavement not the pavement the
parquet and it was you know intricately
cut and based on the parquet of Palace
in st. Petersburg I mean this was a man
who
who really loved a grand style and
wasn't holding back and he wasn't you
know budgeting in fact his father Adolfo
used to say every human being has three
elements that must be kept in balance at
all times a heart a brain and a wallet
and he said if not trouble will come and
pointed trouble calm and Patrizia and
she she admitted this and in court she
was terrified that he was going to spend
all the money and that there would be
nothing left for her and her daughters
so what happened to Patricia on January
31st 1997 so two years later the police
ring her doorbell at four o'clock in the
morning and they come with the papers
they say sonoda you're under arrest for
the murder of your husband and she goes
into a dressing room and to get ready to
go with them
and she comes out and she is dressed in
a floor-length mink coat gold and
diamond jewelry and she's carrying a
Gucci handbag and she's okay I'm ready
let's go and her mother later at the
jailhouse at the police station took the
coat away and took the Gucci handbag and
you know the policeman said you know
sunyata you won't be needing these
things in jail but it really shows and
I'm not trying it to defend her because
you can't excuse what she did but this
was a woman who who just thought she was
going to get home free and she really
didn't think that she was gonna have to
pay for what she did in a way that maybe
she was above it all and to this day she
she maintains her innocence and so do
her daughters and her mother so well the
police had a very interesting story
because for two years they had nothing
and they probably wouldn't have had
anything except an anonymous informant
came forward and he had heard this story
from a porter of a seedy two one-star
hotel and the others
Malan who had been one of the guys that
had gotten involved in the murder and
Patrizia had gone to her friend who was
a Neapolitan psychic who was her best
friend and said you know you got to help
me I cannot live I mean she had built
her hatred of Mauricio into an obsession
and it was and I cannot live until this
man is dead and will somebody please
help me kill my husband and she almost
became famous in Milan because she over
the years had asked several people to
find a killer and her even lawyers who
who then you know later reported these
conversations and so her defense was you
know I said that I wanted to kill him
but I never meant it it was just a way
of speaking anyway the police
reconstructed the story they were doing
they bugged the phones although they
never actually got patrizii on tape or
Pina the the Neapolitan psychic talking
about the murder because they were very
clever and they developed a code
language for talking about the sums of
money that petite she was paying over a
series of months for the murder and
instead of talking about you know the
money they would talk about meters of
fabric and how they'd been to the fabric
store and they'd found some great
fabrics and how many meters and can you
bring them by today and and so the
police figured out actually in
retrospect that this was the code for
for all the financial arrangements and
the the trial lasted five months for
over 500 hours of testimony had covered
the whole thing spent a lot of hours on
the on the courtroom bench in fact took
me back to the days when I was living
here and working with Andy sauna and the
recovery county courthouse and really if
there's one thing that you can see in
the courtroom as a writer is that
there's so many different ways to tell
the story and it's really rich detail
and this trial really opened up the
lives of patrice mo TCO like a book I
mean everybody it seemed who had ever
known them walk through that courtroom
and had their story their piece of the
story to tell so it was really full of
color full of detail
yes she was convicted on November 1998
she was sentenced to jail for 29 years
and there was the judge took into
consideration of mitigating factor
because she had presented an insanity
plea actually she really tried to play
both sides of the fence because on the
one hand the lawyer said that she was
insane because she'd had a brain tumor
and had an operation to remove his brain
tumor so they said she wasn't capable of
understanding her her actions are the
implications of her actions but on the
other hand they said oh she paid all
this money to Pina but it was for a loan
and no either way you've played it she
didn't do it and she was subsequently
reviewed on appeal and they shortened
the sentence by three years so 26 and
the mitigating factor was that although
they didn't find her crazy they said
that she had a personality disorder and
there was a panel of court-appointed
psychiatrist who came in and said that
she had a narcissistic personality and
this meant that as long as everything
was going right for her in her life that
she was fine but when the tide started
to turn against her and things didn't
turn out the way she wanted to every
everything that went wrong became a deep
offense and it became a wound and this
wound festered into this obsession and
when the judge is talking to the the
psychiatrist and trying to get him to
sort of say it in layman's terms what is
this personality disorder because the
term was not not she's East eco history
on eco and to this day I don't figure
out what each three on eco means because
I don't know but the the psychiatrist
said well this means that you can walk
around with your nose in the air but it
doesn't mean that you can kill somebody
because so we can't comprehend why she
did what she did but we can't condone it
and a little detail the day that she was
convicted a pair of
Leeming silver handcuffs showed up in
the Gucci windows and Milan and when all
the reporters called the the press
person to say you know what is this what
does this mean I said it was a
coincidence but you know who knows if if
Tom's Ford sense of humor hasn't gotten
away first with is it known who is
responsible for the original of the
signature three bars degree memory and
built the double cheese and also when
they went about restructure when they
were trying to bring moving yeah
actually this is [ __ ] that's a good
question cuz I jumped it in the
beginning of my talk the whole
development of trademark symbols around
Gucci was really key to its ability to
set itself apart and become a status
symbol and this started with Aldo and
also with his his father Gaucho in the
50s and they started with the writing
imagery so the webbing the horse bit
many of the bags were cut to look like
saddlebags in fact the the famous bamboo
bag which is thought to have been
created in 1947 although they don't
actually have the documents that prove
this because it was very much of a
family thing and maybe the artisan had
an idea maybe one of the family members
had idea and it was kind of a you know
teamwork working today you call them
design teams and these these images
really set these products apart from the
others and one thing that I noticed with
interest there's another family
Florentine leather goods firm called
Franzi which is actually a place where
gucchy worked before he opened his his
store and we just photographed a
briefcase from Franzi for our magazine
Luna and I thought you know they're
still there they're still working
they're still making beautiful leather
goods products but who's ever heard of
Fonzie and everybody's heard of
she so those symbols were really really
key to setting those apart and to bring
the bring it up to today when Tom was
first working Tom Ford was first working
at Gucci and Modi so was still there and
he was focused on a sort of classic
genteel luxury Maurice who used to say
Gucci must be round and brown and the
bags must be soft to a woman's touch and
they must have his characteristics
well as Tom then started getting his
design freedom and his independence he
realized that he didn't want to do round
and brown he wanted to do square and
black and that's exactly what he did and
there was a conscious decision on the
part of Tom Ford and Dominical de Soleil
to not pursue this sort of classic
genteel a path but to hit the fashion
accelerator hard and that's what they
did and so for several years there was
nothing round or brown about Gucci and
it was it was very hard-edged very sexy
very trendy and this just riveted the
attention of the fashion press and a key
blockbuster show in 1995 Joan caner
who's a senior fashion buyer for Neiman
Marcus she said you know it was hot and
she said the girls on the runway looked
like they had just walked off of
somebody's private jet and they were
doing it and having it all and this is
what really put the buzz back in Gucci
now that said after you know they made
that mark and really sort of made a
separation from the past in fact today
if you go into a Gucci store you will
see the Gigi monogram everywhere you
will see the handbags from the past you
will see even their ten historic
handbags that have been brought out
again so you know they're not turning
their backs on on the history on these
icons it's something now that's becoming
re reintegrated we're
into the Gucci style so it comes back
again a lot of these players have a
astrologist or a psychic or spiritual
adviser these these folks play a lot
into what what happens in that
throughout the history of gucci or in a
later part well i mean they didn't
actually sort of make any sort of key
turning points or decisions but yeah
you're right there is this real backdrop
in fact modi still has a psychic that he
goes to and i say at one point you know
he went to talk to this woman as though
as other men and women might go to talk
to a financial adviser or a psychologist
and mona lisa was a very shy and
reserved man who didn't have a lot of
friends it was a very lonely man and at
one point there's this woman who he was
going to and she was really the only
person that he could talk to openly and
she they would meet for coffee or for
cappuccino near the Duomo which was near
the money to his offices in Milan and he
would sneak away you know turn off his
cell phone nobody would know where he'd
gone and they would sit down he would
said she would say Maurizio Julie
mesquita take down the mask and and he
would talk to her and he would run his
business plans by her because he felt
that somehow she gave him the the
confidence and the support that he
needed to to do what he wanted to do
yes propelled you to rank the story or
were you in the process of writing a
story and then the sensational thing
happened no actually um for several
actually for a long time after the
murder I decided not to write the story
because one we didn't know who done it
and it was really sinister and so I
didn't want to like start poking around
and get in trouble and - it was so sad
that I felt that there had to be
something redeeming about the story and
it wasn't until the company actually
really achieved its turnaround that I
felt like there was the the maybe not
the final piece of the story but that
there was kind of an evolution of the
story that could sustain the book and in
fact one of my final note cards here is
that I really came to feel as I was
writing this book that this is a saga
that is never ending and when I started
writing the book it was actually just
the beginning of the whole financial
takeover chapter which is one of the
which is the last chapter in the book
and I realized that you know what had
been this mom-and-pop handbag shop was
now you know appetizing - one of the the
biggest luxury goods Baron's in the
industry but not of no and so my feeling
is that you know this the story this
name is just going to continue to be a
trailblazer and to be sort of throwing
out news and interesting twists and
turns I don't know what's going to
happen next but I'm watching translated
in Italian well it's out with the
Italian publishers but the interesting
thing is apparently Americans are a lot
more interested in family dynasties and
conflicts than the Italians are and as I
was writing the book you know when the
trial was going on for example happened
I'd go out to dinner and and people say
oh you know the goat cheese and oh you
know we're not that interested and I
know Italians aren't that interested and
then we'd start talking because
inevitably
the conversation would go into the story
and everybody around the table had
always read the sort of see me details
in that day's paper so they were
pooh-poohing this story but everybody
was you know reading down to the last
gruff so so we'll see you're gonna you
feel not Italian yes yes and I think
that being able to talk to many of these
people in Italian really helped me get
the flavor of the story and they
understood that I understood you know
what they were dealing with and I
interviewed artisans and Florence and
people had worked for the company people
who'd known you know part of the
problems in writing even the history
with a narrative approach a novelistic
approach was that a lot of the people
weren't around anymore
no I never met Aldo I never met Paolo
and so I had to get people who known
them to really tell me what they were
like and what their personalities were
like hear me say according to Sunday and
but most of the times you're doing how
do you decide when to say according to I
don't know depends on if I felt that it
needed maybe a little bit more sort of
authenticity or whether it was something
sometimes that I would write something
that was really based on information
that I'd gleaned from a lot of different
sources and so I felt that I had enough
to make the statement I should say I had
about thirty five pages of chapter notes
that got cut from the book because it
was too long and in there I had
identified every single quote and who
had said it so we're thinking maybe
that'll go up on a website somewhere but
it's still in my computer right now yeah
could you women if you women
participated all in the biz
that's an interesting story because over
the years yeah there had been Gucci
women who participated in one of the
first was goody Malda who was the
daughter of the founder and he started
the the litigation right away because
when he died she found out that only her
brothers had been given a stake in the
business and it turned out that GU chose
policy was that no woman should ever
hold stake in Gucci and even his own
daughter and she had stood behind the
tables her husband had helped finance
the company and its early struggles he
designed the factory in Florence and yet
she found that instead of a stake in the
company she was left a farmhouse and
some money and she actually took her
brother's to court you know pain pained
to be doing this and according to her
account she misunderstood a key question
in the procedure and he said yes I agree
and so it ended and she had agreed to to
the settlement but not to having the
stake in the business I could say
something he's a good
there are many famous designers many
years which everyone's favorite and
wicked or well I mean I think right now
that is the two labels that you really
look to are Gucci and Prada and it's a
very lively sort of competition between
the two and they've really taken over
the Milan fashion scene the way once
upon a time Armani and Versace had so
when I first started covering fashion
the shows that you really wanted to go
to wear Armani and Versace and one was
kind of cool and chic and the other was
hot and sexy and I have got Prada which
is your minimalist and sort of fashion
insider and you got Gucci which is hot
and sexy so in a way you know the
industry sort of updating itself and now
these are the two the two tickets you
know if you're a fear of Milan covering
fashion those are the two shows you have
to go to she could have gotten involved
in company she wanted to in fact this is
a she really wanted to role in the
company to the point where some of my
adityas advisors were overtly telling
her potata stay out of the business but
an italian friend of mine said to me
recently she said no sara pains me to
say this to you but I really think that
in Italy still today there is not a lot
available for women outside of marriage
and so I think if you are an aggressive
ambitious woman like Patricia she would
you know didn't bother to try to set up
business on her own she found the man
with the name and the fame and the
fortune and she was going to do it that
way so and she was really you know
pushed aside and she did not welcome her
into the business and he did not want
her interfering in the business and that
was a key reason for their estrangement
yeah
did you actually interview Patrizia and
what was your impression of her we do
but Lisa called me up in 1993 I was at
Women's Wear Daily and W and this was
right before Modi - had lost control of
the company and she was trying to help
him find money because he had at one
point put his shares up as collateral
for personal loans and what came out and
surprised everybody was at all this you
know Meg apartment and he had a luxury
yacht a three-masted schooner that he
was redoing and he was spending borrowed
money gambling that when he turned
around Gucci he was going to get it all
back and so he'd put his shares up as
collateral the banks were calling in the
loans the company was going down and
Patrizia helped him get a loan that
saved him in the nick of time and
there's an incredible story about as a
sort of intermediary his name was
misspelled me Johnny which we think was
probably a fake name you know the the
miniskirts and the fishnets and the
cleavage and mr. padmi Johnny made the
overture to maurices lawyer and in the
span of a weekend 48 hours there were 40
million dollars in a bank account so
mateesah could get his shares back and
so petit SIA wanted people to know that
she had done this and it wasn't for her
love of mony Co but is because she
didn't want him to lose the company and
that she fell only only if he had the
company was he going to be able to
provide for her and her daughters and at
the same time and you'll see in the book
there's a there's a point where she
sends him a cassette tape and tells him
you know just bidding out her fury at
him and you know you're a terrible
person and you know you've got your
Fatah T's and your mr. Presidente but
here we are you know and and the couches
you know needs repairing and the parquet
is you know broken and and she started a
campaign against him to discredit him
and she really worked particularly
American press to try and get them to
listen to her and she wanted me to write
a story for W sort of a gossip story
with her story and in the end I didn't
write the story but it was a fascinating
interview and she was sitting on the
couch and the hair and and she do showed
me the scar where this brain tumor had
been removed and she'd survived so you
know really delicate operation and had
hair implants to cover it so you
couldn't see the scar and it was just
she was just an incredible I'm kind of a
person now then I tried to to interview
her in jail you know sort of fast
forward to to 1998 and I made three
different requests to the Italian penal
authorities to interview her and what I
found is that they don't have the
free-speech considerations that we have
here and I even got into two local jails
here as a to do a freelance piece about
women on death row I didn't even have at
that point a name of a newspaper you
know to to justify the story it was just
a personal project and I got in and in
Milan I had no luck and they just said
that they were rejecting the interview
pad motiva the opportunity ah meaning it
was inopportune but not explaining why
so so I was pretty frustrated about that
and what I did was I started writing to
her because you can write to people in
jail and they can write you back and we
started a correspondence and I didn't
really want to get into the issues of
the trial because I knew she was just
gonna give me the spiel that her lawyers
were giving and I pretty much knew what
her defense was but I went back and
asked her to talk to me about the
details of her relationship with
Maurizio and their early romance and his
courtship and and the early years of
their marriage and and she wasn't
answering my letters and so I finally
because I was writing to her in English
because it was easier for me and quicker
and I finally wrote and I said I realize
maybe you're not answering me because
I'm writing to you in English I just
want to let you know I've lived in Italy
for many years I speak fluent Italian
I'd be perfectly happy if you
would answer me in Italian and I
understand it and that popped her first
letter and she answered me in perfect
English I think I got into her pride and
here she'd gone to translate her school
but her English was really quite good
and so that was the that was the secret
that opened the Pandora's box
yes considered the first news of per se
of gucci like the woman that personified
the early gucci image or were there
other famous women at the time that gave
the design team inspiration right well
particular was always very over-the-top
and she was considered sort of very
nouveau riche and that um it wasn't
really gucci style there are other women
especially well starting even in the 50s
there was a Walt Grace Kelly Grace Kelly
wore Gucci and in fact an adult for
Gucci designed the famous floor scarf
for her and that's a wonderful story
this was you know she'd come into the
store to look around and and he heard
that she was there and came running down
from his office and he showed her around
and as she was leaving he said you may
give you a gift and she said she'd
immured and didn't want anything he said
no no I insist insist and she said well
okay what about a scarf what she didn't
know is that at that time Gucci didn't
really have any scarves that Adolfo
thought were right for a princess and
they had little sort of small scars with
trains and so did they were more almost
more childish and so he said well what
kind of scarf did you have in mind
trying to stall for time and she said
well how about something with flowers on
it
it's was thinking and he didn't have
anything with flowers on it so he gave
her one of the Gucci bamboo handled bags
and the minute she left the store he
called an artist that he'd known from
his acting days and he called it you got
to come to me line you gotta come to LA
we've got to do this scarf and they met
the artists name was our coordinator and
Rodolfo says to him I want a scarf it's
a cornucopia of flowers so that
everywhere you every way you look at
every we turn it all you see a flower so
I called Nana went back and sketch the
scarf and he was sketch on paper with
the colored pencils and he came back and
presented a sketch and it was exactly
what Adolfo had wanted and he gave it to
an important silk manufacturer in Como
which is just a few hours not even an
hour half an hour from Milan and at that
time the silk manufacturer had developed
a technique where he could print many
different colors without the colors
bleeding and so this is really the
beginning of the whole line of silk
products and then later silk clothing
for Gucci and there was something like
42 colors in this scarf and none of them
none of them bled and so al Adolfo had
the scarf hand-delivered to to Grace
Kelly and that was the story behind the
creation of yet another one of these
Gucci icons and they later used that
motif for umbrellas I mean it became a
rich a rich source of inspiration for
them just to finish answering a question
also about other women who really sort
of took up the Gucci style another one
was Jackie Onassis and in fact there's a
picture in the book of her carrying a
handbag and that handbag was reissued in
last year and it was one of the most
successful bags in the industry so there
was a real connection between these
stylish women and these stylish products
all right that is one more recover from
this do you have another project in mind
well I'm gonna go back and keep working
on Luna the magazine which is a really a
full-time project for now and I got a
couple of book ideas percolating but
nothing nothing as rich as this right
now
thank you very much for coming it's a
really great